another uh breaking news story that
we're also covering here on Al Jer and
that's that Israel's high court has
struck down a law passed by the knesset
that would have limited its judicial
oversight of government now Israel has
no written Constitution but the court
has long used a so-called reasonableness
standard to decide whether government
decisions are legal prime minister
Benyamin Netanyahu wanted an end to this
standard after the court blocks some of
his cabinet appointments because of
their past criminal convictions it's far
widespread protests throughout 2023 with
critics saying that the move would
increase corruption Laura Khan joins us
now from occupied East Jerusalem and
it's hard to believe that this is the
end of the matter Laura for either the
government or the
public uh it's very unlikely to be the
end of the matter it is the it was a
very bold move by the Supreme Court it's
the first time it has struck down a a
basic law in its history now this law um
was passed in July I was outside the
knesset there were tens of thousands of
people there all protesting against this
law because it's part of a big judicial
overhaul which they say is stripping
away the Supreme Court Powers therefore
taking away the checks and balances
needed uh this reasonableness uh Bill
the Clause has been used for around four
decades and it allows the Supreme Court
to take itions from the government um
when it comes to anything from
appointing ministers or judgments that
they believe is unreasonable um so there
has been some reaction so far um the
kapan force one of the big protest
movements they've already put out a
statement um saying you know that they
need to celebrate this this is a big
victory uh for the big movement against
the judicial overhaul the Justice
Minister who was one of the architects
of this law says you know at a time
where we need unity in the country we're
not getting that we need to unite behind
the fighters and this certainly
shouldn't have happened um dur or the
the overturn of the law shouldn't have
happened during the war on Gaza Laura KH
thanks very much for joining us for the
update there Let's cross over to Gideon
Levy is a columnist with haret newspaper
joins us now live from Tel Aviv Mr Levy
good to have you with us on the program
again is the court now on a collision
course with the prime minister
yes absolutely and H the Supreme Court
took us back today for a moment to the
days before the 7th of October namely
let's forget about the war and let's
remember what happened in Israel in the
last year in the last year there was a
very very bitter struggle over the
nature of Israel's democracy namely that
the government and the Parliament try to
to take some anti-democratic measures
the Supreme Court of Israel sa it its
voice today raised its voice today in a
very clear and Loud way and put an end
to all the What's called the legal or
juristic reform that Nan's Government
tried to to implement and we are back
with a more healthy system what do you
think prime minister netanyahu's options
are now do you think he's going to well
I think we both think he's not going to
just sit down and take this but what how
do you think he's going to move forward
on
this the matter of fact is that there is
very little that which can be done
except of Anarchy I mean if we continue
to be a state of law there's nothing he
can do because even if the parliament
will now legislate another basic law now
it's very clear that the Supreme Court
has the sovereign has the right to
cancel it so it can become an endless
game the the parliament will legislate
and the Supreme Court will cancel it so
I don't see much that can be done
because the Supreme Court was so clear
with a very very clear majority certain
judges out of 15 say that the Supreme
Court has the right to canel basic laws
of the parliament if they are not
illegal I think it's a very important
day for for Israel's democracy but let's
remember we are in a very special time
in which the Israel's democracy is
killing children and civilians in Gaza
how much pressure is the prime minister
under now I mean he's got the war on
Gaza which obviously we we know about
but he's also got quite a a divided
right-wing cabinet as
well yeah but he can still survive I
mean let's not have any let's not be
wrong netan can continue to be the prime
minister at least for the end of the war
maybe longer who knows he has a very
stable majority and this majority this
Coalition will not commit suicide and
will not go against him because once
they go against him that's the end of
this government and elections means now
in
Israel a totally different government so
I don't see them taking a suicidal steps
and I think that this government can
last for long we'll see what happens
certainly in the coming weeks for the
moment Gideon Levy there from haret
newspaper in Tel thank you very much for
your time sir